while we are trying to understand
we want to know as much as we can about the population.
the most important
characteristic
about
population about a population about its
sample
is its average?
We might not be able to know everything we want to know
about.
A population of population of people a population
of elephants a population of smartphones you name it a
population doesn't have to do with people it can be living things.
It can be, you know products.
That are sold in a store.
Okay, but it has to do with with entirety.
We can't know everything there is to know we can't know every
single detail about.
population
but
we can know a great deal about its average.
If you look at people we want to know the average height of
people the average weight of people average income
of people.
the average concentration
of people in an urban area
Okay, they were always be allies but the averages will
be more helpful to us. Of course. The outliers
are important.
But the average is you know, what?
What we're more concerned about let's say
you are a marketing or let's say you're a retail company.
And you sell?
luxury bags
He said luxury bags and your target audience.
Are people who have more disposable income?
and you have to decide where to
advertise
Let's see you you have a you want
to advertise that people in the shopping mall? Okay, let's forget about
digital marketing for a second.
Forget about online ads and videos and Instagram
and all of that.
You want to place a ad in the shopping mall that
says?
A new bags for the season by the
great white one of the best designers ever.
Where in that shopping mall, would you place that at?
Okay, you can't obviously plaster on that everywhere. That's not
going to work. You need to be selected with where you put that advertisement.
You need to figure out for example, this is where the the
idea of averages will come on average. Most people with
more with the high disposable income where they spend their time.
Do they spend their time at the dollar store?
Are they it you know in the
food court where there is.
Fast food probably not they probably spend there.
time
at some restaurant where you know
like a three Michelin three star three Michelin
star restaurant, you know fine dining or there's
On the second floor for example or the fifth for whatever where they
sell jewelry and watches.
so, you know, okay the bulk of my
I'm not saying people who have high disposable then come don't go don't have
McDonald's but the majority of them if they're in the shopping mall, let's
say they would spend their time. Let's see
in the upper levels.
where the
luxury brands are
You know.
They exist.
So she okay. It will be best if we would have the most.
Attraction most traction if we put our ads in
that part of the shopping mall because the majority
the majority of the average of our
demographic our Target demographic is in
that part.
Now that's just one example.
of how
knowing about the average or understanding average is going to
Help you make better decisions. This is true. Whether
you're right whether you're in Commerce in you
know in healthcare.
Manufacturing and Space Engineering.
You name it?
statistics and probability Theory
are important in all areas.
But what you see here are three key terms?
three things that describe
this
the idea of the average in statistics and probability now, we
will come we will I will talk about these if you don't know what these three
means. I will Define it for you.
But perhaps the most important.
of these three
is the mean
Okay, in fact so important it is.
It's so important.
that there was a special kind of
mean